[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur tv18 nous sommes le
jeudi 10 novembre voici le programme
aujourd'hui c'est la journée nationale
de lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
l'occasion de rappeler combien la
prévention est fondamentale car près
d'un élève sur 10 et victimes de
harcèlement à des degrés différents dans
ce cadre la commune des mureaux
participé au programme PHARE nous en
parlerons avec notre invité depuis 2015
la brasserie La Petite sœur basée à
Sartrouville produit de la bière
artisanale dans cette émission nous vous
ferons découvrir les coulisses de
fabrication nous vous parlerons
également du projet de bière
collaborative menée avec des habitants
des Yvelines et puis à l'approche de ce
week-end de prolongée nous vous
donnerons nos idées de sortie dans les
Yvelines concert exposition marché
d'automne ce sera avec notre journaliste
Gabriel Gontier et avec moi un plateau
Nathalie jeta bonsoir vous êtes la
directrice de
la directrice pardon de l'atelier des
Yvelines du réseau canopé le réseau
canopée qui travaille avec le ministère
de l'Éducation nationale et qui a pour
mission d'accompagner le développement
professionnel des enseignants et
aujourd'hui vous étiez au Mureaux dans
le cadre de la Journée mondiale de la
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire car
vous avez accompagné des écoles de la
commune dans ce projet phare alors
première question est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer ce qu'est le projet phare
alors c'est un programme plus qu'un
projet ce programme PHARE permet aux
établissements de de d'inscrire un
certain nombre d'actions qui permettent
de lutter contre le harcèlement ça
concerne aussi bien tout le personnel
scolaire des établissements mais aussi
également les les parents et les élèves
aujourd'hui
nous avons nous sommes allés du coup
dans la cité des Mureaux pour travailler
avec trois collèges et de lycée sur
cette thématique du harcèlement pour
former des élèves qui deviennent
ambassadeurs
contre le harcèlement donc on en parlera
dans quelques instants avec moi
également sur ce plateau Claudine et
Jean-François Husson bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes les présidents de
l'association un enfant une famille qui
est basée à Marly-le-Roi est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi est-ce
que vous avez décidé de créer cette
association cette association qui je le
rappelle permet à des enfants et des
familles isolées de favoriser leur
intégration et de créer des liens
sociaux
initialement on a des parents adoptifs
et quand on a adopté notre premier
enfant les dames nous ont dit c'est le
seul qui sortira tous les autres
resteront jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans et du
coup à l'époque on était membre d'une
association d'adoptant on a rencontré
Jeanine et Antoine rébello qui avait
fondé cette association un enfant une
famille et ça nous a paru tellement
important qu'on a vite militaire pour le
parrainage beaucoup plus pour que pour
l'adoption voilà et vous avez décidé du
coup de la créer dans les Yvelines alors
au départ non parce que au départ on
était à Toulouse donc on a créé une
association qui s'appelle un enfant des
parrains mais qui fonctionne pareil et
quand on est venu
dans les idées en région parisienne au
départ on a pris on a eu beaucoup de
travail parce que on est enseigné etc et
puis quand on a commencé à avoir à être
près de la retraite on a pris la suite
des rébellos voilà et ça fait 10 ans
qu'on est maintenant président
d'association et donc on en parlera dans
quelques instants mais tout d'abord je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'oeil à
la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin dans les Yvelines le ciel
sera brumeux et le soleil aura un peu de
mal à sortir au niveau des températures
il fera 8 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 7
degrés à Versailles et 6 degrés à Houdan
et Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le
soleil sera bien présent sur tout le
département au niveau des températures
comptées 12 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et aux dents à rembouiller il
fera 11 degrés
le point maintenant sur l'actualité du
jour dans les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Céline Charles on
commence avec la Journée nationale de
lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire on
en parlait à l'instant oui c'est notre
image du jour au Mureaux s'est tenu un
hackathon non au harcèlement une journée
de sensibilisation auprès des lycéens et
collégiens des ateliers se sont déroulés
avec les professeurs pour trouver des
solutions contre le harcèlement dans les
établissements objectifs former 50
élèves ambassadeurs un chiffre
exceptionnel à noter il concerne la
circulation de ce jeudi 10 novembre plus
de 330 km de bouchons ont été recensés
ce jeudi matin sur les routes
d'Île-de-France à 8h citadins recensait
même exactement 338 km d'embouteillage
un trafic à un niveau inhabituel qui
peut s'expliquer par la greffe du jour
pour les salaires et les retraites le
trafic a été très perturbé sur le réseau
des transports en commun une situation
qui restera tendue ce soir sur les actes
les axes routiers en ce début de
week-end prolongé à 17h il y avait 362
kilomètres de bouchons recensés en
Île-de-France attention donc si de vous
devez prendre la route Bison Futé voire
rouge en Île-de-France dans le sens des
départs aujourd'hui le trafic s'annonce
très chargé notamment sur l'autoroute
A13 et A10 en direction de la province
un pic de bouchon est attendu aux
alentours de 19h les retours dimanche
pourraient également être compliqué
l'île de France et classé orange Bison
Futé recommande de rejoindre ou
traverser l'Île-de-France avant midi et
d'éviter la barrière de péage de
Saint-Arnoult entre 15h et 21h un
incident aurait été passé sous silence
par le SSIAP du département 4 tonnes de
biogaz ont été accidentellement relâchés
dans l'atmosphère sur le site de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye HR c'est une
information de nos confrères de 78 actus
l'incident a eu lieu dans la nuit du 9
au 10 octobre dernier l'information n'a
été transmise que le 21 octobre auprès
des services de l'État le site avait
déjà connu un incident majeur en juillet
2019 une pollution de la scène survenue
après l'incendie de l'usine plus de 3
tonnes de poissons étaient morts
asphyxie après un incendie au sein de la
structure du sport à présent avec
l'annonce de la composition de l'équipe
de France de football qui s'envolera
pour le Qatar dans quelques jours oui
mathilde a une semaine et demi du début
de la Coupe du Monde 2022 la liste des
25 joueurs de l'équipe de France a été
dévoilé par Didier Deschamps le
sélectionneur de l'équipe parmi les
joueurs retenus un yvelin le milieu de
terrain de Marseille Matéo gain Douzi on
retrouve aussi des Bleus formés dans le
département Areola kimpembe rabiot koman
et n kuntu sont tous passés par le
centre d'entraînement du PSG à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qu'il y a même
vapé lui a fait ses classes dans les
rangs du Centre national de football à
Clairefontaine Clairefontaine d'ailleurs
où les Bleus vont se rassembler lundi et
mardi prochain avant de s'envoler pour
le Qatar mercredi 16 novembre premier
match de l'équipe de France le 22
novembre face à l'Australie ce sera à Al
wakra Aujourd'hui Sport Céline on fait
le point sur la Route du Rhum oui les
trois les 138 skippers sont partis hier
de Saint-Malo et ont pris la direction
de Pointe-à-Pitre Guadeloupe pour la
compétition la Route du Rhum de livinois
sont engagés parmi les 38 marins de la
catégorie IMOCA Eric Bellion avec son
bateau comme un seul homme power by
Altavia et Louis Burton avec son nouveau
bateau Bureau Vallée au deuxième
pointage au dernier pointage Eric Brion
se classait 11e du classement IMOCA
Louis Burton se classait à lui à la 7e
place un mot de culture pour terminer
avec une annonce pour les apprentis
comédiens pour les curieux et oui et si
vous deveniez acteur le temps d'une
journée la production du film Les rois
de la piste cherchent des figurants pour
le rôle de clients d'une boîte de nuit
le tournage se déroulera à Limay le
mercredi 16 novembre prochain les
candidats doivent avoir entre 20 et 35
ans et une priorité sera donnée bien sûr
aux yvelinois dans le recrutement Fanny
Ardant Mathieu Kassovitz c'est Nicolas
Duvauchelle seront feront partie du
casting vous pouvez postuler rendez-vous
sur le site casse prod merci beaucoup
Céline Charles et comme d'habitude si
vous voyez des informations près de chez
vous que vous vous souhaitez nous
partager n'hésitez pas à le faire avec
le hashtag 78 news sur Twitter
[Musique]
j'en parlais en début d'émission
aujourd'hui c'est la journée nationale
de lutte contre le harcèlement scolaire
des élèves et enseignants de plusieurs
établissements yvelinois se sont réunis
ce jeudi 10 novembre au Mureaux le but
de cette journée trouver des solutions
et Patrick Jacques de Dixmude Regine
rage se sont rendus sur place regardez
nationale contre le harcèlement qui
concerne absolument tous les
établissements mettre fin au harcèlement
scolaire telle est l'objectif de cette
journée des élèves et leurs enseignants
réfléchissent à la question ils se sont
réunis ce jeudi 10 novembre au pôle
Molière des Mureaux à l'issue de cette
journée des élèves ambassadeurs ont été
désignés pour se faire porte-parole de
la lutte contre le harcèlement bad Demba
est l'un d'entre eux quand j'étais au
collège j'avais des amis qui se
faisaient harceler parce que ils étaient
ils avaient des handicaps et
parce que quand il devait passer au
tableau il avait pas compris ou parce
qu'ils étaient pas à fond dans le corps
à cause des élèves qui les harcèdent et
du coup ça fait baisser la moyenne et
ils ont mal fini l'année
l'encadrement scolaire est lui aussi
très actif sur la question enseignante
proviseur conseillé principaux ils sont
nombreux à avoir répondu présent
aujourd'hui je suis là pour mettre en
place des actions contre le harcèlement
dans mon lycée
c'est encore à l'état embryonnaire et je
cherche des idées avec mes équipes pour
trouver le moyen d'améliorer la
situation les ambassadeurs sont là
aujourd'hui donc voilà là c'est le c'est
un peu embryonnaire comme on dit là
c'est vraiment on est en train de lancer
avec les élèves et puis après ces
ambassadeurs là donc déjà vont arriver
dans l'établissement avec qui a été
travaillé aujourd'hui et puis ensuite on
va les former en tout cas pour au moins
qui est sensibilise les autres de
l'établissement 100% des collèges et des
lycées de l'académie de Versailles sont
engagés et 50% ont d'ores et déjà
participé au programme de formation donc
on progresse et on a un plan un plan
d'action pour couvrir tout le monde
depuis 2 ans des ateliers de ce type
sont organisés chaque année le
harcèlement scolaire toucherait encore
entre 800 000 et 1 million d'élèves en
France
et justement Nathalie jeta vous avez
participé à cette journée aux Mureaux je
le rappelle vous êtes la directrice des
ateliers des Yvelines pour le réseau
canopée le réseau canopé qui travaille
avec le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale tout à l'heure vous nous
expliquez un petit peu les piliers de ce
programme PHARE est-ce que toutes les
écoles et tous les établissements de
France font suivent ce programme PHARE
alors comme la préciser Madame la
Rectrice effectivement c'est
accessible à tous les établissements
c'est un programme qui se fait sur deux
ans ou la liberté est laissée aux
établissements pour organiser des
actions de lutte contre le harcèlement
des actions de sensibilisation aussi
bien au niveau des des enseignants que
que des élèves ou encore que des parents
parce que les parents sont également mis
dans la boucle sur ce programme
alors il peut y avoir différents types
d'actions je sais que dans certains
collèges ou dans certains lycées sont
organisés par exemple des cafés des
parents pour les recevoir discuter avec
eux ça permet justement d'identifier et
puis de d'expliquer aussi ce qu'est le
harcèlement parce que c'est la peut-être
la priorité c'est déjà de définir
véritablement ce qu'est le harcèlement
beaucoup d'élèves sont victimes de
harcèlement et n'osent pas en parler en
pensant que c'est normal et puis à
contrario il y a un certain nombre
d'élèves qui pensent pareil pour les
parents que leurs enfants sont victimes
de harcèlement alors que ça n'a pas
forcément été le cas donc il est
important peut-être de commencer par
clarifier ce qu'est le harcèlement pour
pouvoir essayer de sensibiliser un
maximum de personnes et du coup d'agir
sur sur ça et comment faire justement
pour clarifier ce qu'est le harcèlement
est-ce que vous avez des outils à
disposition alors il y a beaucoup
d'outils qui sont à disposition pour
pour ça et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu un
certain nombre de capsules vidéos qui
ont été faites l'Académie a énormément
travailler aussi sur ses actions là on
peut trouver beaucoup de enfin il y a
des concours par exemple qui sont
accessibles aux établissements comme aux
élèves il y a plein de vidéos qui qui
circulent sur le harcèlement
réseau canopée très engagé aussi sur le
harcèlement avec des programmes à
destination des enseignants comme des
élèves on a un certain nombre de
ressources qui sont à leur disposition
également donc oui je pense qu'il y a il
y a quand même beaucoup de choses mais
il reste évidemment beaucoup de travail
à faire parce que je pense qu'on a enfin
on commence véritablement à parler de
harcèlement alors que ce harcèlement est
présent quand même depuis longtemps et
c'est peut-être même accentué depuis
Internet et Internet les réseaux sociaux
et puis le fait que maintenant il y a
pas un seul élève sans un portable
Grégory vous avez une question
justement c'était sur ce harcèlement qui
qui évolue à l'époque où j'étais au
collège au lycée on ne parlait pas
forcément encore de réseaux sociaux ça
commençait tout juste là le harcèlement
finalement peut continuer à la maison
c'est ce qui peut-être 10 différencie
par rapport à avant ou on était
seulement sur du harcèlement à l'école
là ça peut aussi prendre des proportions
et se poursuivre à l'extérieur de
l'école absolument c'est très sournois
puisque quand on parle de harcèlement en
général on identifie plus facilement le
harcèlement scolaire physique parce que
il est visible mais dès qu'on parle de
harcèlement de cyber-harcèlement c'est
déjà beaucoup plus compliqué de le
déceler parce que ça va se faire surtout
en dehors de l'école alors ça peut
rentrer aussi dans l'école se poursuivre
dans l'école mais très souvent ça
commence ça peut commencer tout
simplement dans la chambre du jeune sans
que même les parents s'en aperçoivent
donc là par exemple pour le
cyber-harcèlement il serait peut-être
intéressant de sensibiliser les parents
au fait qu'il existe un certain nombre
d'applications qui permettent justement
de peut-être de couper les réseaux
sociaux ou en tout cas de les limiter et
du coup de de
voilà de d'être actif en tout cas par
rapport par rapport à ça malheureusement
et on l'a vu encore aujourd'hui madame
lactrice a posé clairement la question
aux jeunes qui étaient présents
aujourd'hui
de en leur demandant qui
qui a une application qui fait usage
d'une application et je sur le nombre
d'élèves qu'il y avait aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il y en a trois qui ont levé la
main
[Musique]
ça a servi à déceler des problèmes
certes mais pas uniquement ça a servi
notamment pour ses élèves ambassadeurs
qui étaient tous volontaires pour être
formés donc ils se sont proposés pour
être élèves ambassadeurs ça a permis de
de
les former de les informer mais aussi de
de réfléchir avec eux sur les actions
qui pouvaient monter en établissement
puisque le fait d'être ambassadeur c'est
pas uniquement être sensibilisé en
repérant ce qui se passe à l'école mais
c'est aussi agir et pour agir ils ont
besoin de monter des projets
monter des projets quand on est tout
seul et qu'on a été
nommé ambassadeurs c'est pas forcément
évident donc l'idée d'aujourd'hui avec
ce qu'il faut rendre à César ce qui
appartient à César et donc avec monsieur
heathing qui est le Proviseur du au
collège Jules Verne mais aussi le
copilote du programme phare pour la cité
éducative c'est lui qui nous a contacté
qui nous a demandé clairement si on
pouvait faire quelque chose pour les
aider à former ces élèves ambassadeur
donc on est dans le cas du programme
PHARE clairement en les formant sur ses
actions mais du coup on a réfléchi tous
ensemble avec la cité éducative avec les
collèges et les lycées qui voulaient
s'impliquer dedans à ce qu'on pouvait
proposer à ses élèves pour qu'ils aient
vraiment des actions concrètes qui
puissent mettre en place sur le terrain
quand ils vont rentrer dans leurs
établissements et l'idée c'est même
d'aller plus loin c'est de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait
des connexions c'est à dire que ces
projets puissent être des projets
interétablissement aussi
ça permet de
d'aller au delà des tabous de libérer la
parole parce qu'on l'a compris c'est
aussi ça qui est important dans cette
thématique ça permet de libérer la
parole on l'a vu aujourd'hui puisque les
jeunes qui sont arrivés arrivé de
collège et de lycées différents et que
on les a forcément mis en équipe donc
dans une équipe on avait des jeunes qui
venaient des différents collèges et
lycées et donc il a fallu qu'ils
commencent déjà par
s'amadoué par apprendre à se connaître
un minimum pour pouvoir réfléchir
ensemble mais comme on avait une
thématique qui était quand même une
thématique forte qui les préoccupait
tous ça a été assez simple grâce
notamment à Caton et avec toutes ces
techniques de créativité qui permettent
de libérer la parole et qui permettent
de les mettre en action et puis de les
mettre en réflexion d'arriver à produire
des choses alors certes certaines sont
encore embryonnaires et demandent à
peut-être à être réinvestis un petit peu
mais ils sont tous repartis
contents avec
des notions assez claires de ce qui est
le harcèlement le cyber-harcèlement et
aussi avec des actions qui peuvent
continuer sur le terrain et l'envie
surtout de partager entre eux et
pourquoi pas de faire plusieurs choses
plusieurs actions en commun et bien
merci beaucoup Nathalie Jetta d'être
venu en parler avec nous un plateau je
le rappelle vous êtes la directrice des
ateliers des Yvelines pour le réseau
canopée et si vous êtes victime ou
témoin d'un acte de harcèlement à
l'école n'hésitez pas à contacter le
30/20 ou à vous rendre sur le site
internet qui s'affiche à l'écran pour le
cyber-harcèlement un autre numéro exit
existe le 30 18 vous avez également un
chat à disposition sur le site net
écoute.fr on en parlait tout à l'heure
depuis
1978 l'association un enfant une famille
a permis à des familles isolées de
favoriser leur intégration et de créer
des liens sociaux et Gabriel Gontier a
rencontré Aurélie et Alice toute de
membres de l'association regardez
[Musique]
toutes les deux semaines Aurélie
marraine au sein de l'association un
enfant une famille accueille avec son
mari Alice une fillette de 6 ans au
programme de la journée un atelier
maquillage pour préparer Halloween en
compagnie d'Elliott le neveu doré
[Musique]
ces sessions photos pour la filleule et
sa marraine Alice et aurélie s'empresse
de partager le moment avec les parents
de la petite fille tu veux faire une
vidéo à papa et maman pour leur montrer
[Musique]
maintenant
[Rires]
mais je passe une très bonne j'espère
que la chanson vous plaît
voilà gros bisous à tous les trois
originaire du Rwanda en arrivant seul en
France les parents d'Alice souhaitaient
retrouver des liens familiaux pour leurs
enfants d'où l'importance de la
proximité car pour les vacances Alice va
passer quelques jours dans sa famille
d'accueil je reste chez ma marraine pour
dormir 4 jours
oui on va aller voir un parc où il y
aura des animaux une famille par
extension où chacun trouve son intérêt
pour Aurélie dont la maman a été famille
d'accueil à l'azo toute son enfance
c'est avant tout un engagement citoyen
et une aventure humaine moi je la vois
vraiment comme une comme une aventure
gagnant-gagnant c'est à dire
qu'évidemment on apporte à l'enfant
l'ouverture des activités qui ne connaît
pas forcément mais nous aussi on apprend
énormément et vraiment c'est ouais c'est
moi je trouve que c'est une aventure qui
est vraiment gagnant-gagnant et je la
conseille à tout le monde parce que
c'est super chouette on vit des super
moments et puis c'est super enrichissant
[Musique]
[Rires]
après près d'un an passé ensemble la
famille d'Alice fait partie intégrante
de la vie d'Aurélie et son mari une
chance pour la petite fille car comme le
dit le proverbe africain il faut tout un
village pour élever un enfant au revoir
et on retrouve un plateau Gabriel
Gontier bonsoir alors vous avez pu
suivre Aurélie et Alice toute cette
après-midi qu'est-ce qui vous a le plus
marqué durant le tournage de ce
reportage je pense que les images
parlent d'elles-mêmes Mathilde c'est la
complicité entre Alice et Aurélie qui
est très importante ça fait un an
qu'elle se connaissent elles sont déjà
très très proches on voyait dans le
titre une famille par extension et je
crois que c'est vraiment le lien qui les
unit on sent aurélie a ému quand vous
lui posez des questions oui tout à fait
oui oui elle est vraiment émue comme je
vous l'ai dit c'est un lien très fort
qui s'est créé entre les deux enfin
Elvis passe une grande partie de ses
vacances à chaque fois chez Aurélie et
son mari donc c'est un lien fort entre
les deux et donc on a été rejoint un
plateau par Claudine et Jean-François
Husson on en parlait un petit peu de la
création de cette association un enfant
une famille au tout début de l'émission
comment ça se passe si on veut devenir
parrain ou marraine pour pour
l'association comment est-ce qu'on fait
alors le contact donc on a un protocole
qui a été établi depuis le début de
l'association qui fait comme que ça
puisse fonctionner on rencontre les gens
deux fois alors en fait les rencontres
c'est surtout des échanges c'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement
on est des bénévoles qui avons parrainer
donc on est capable de témoigner de
parrainage auprès des candidats
l'idée comme on l'a vu là c'est
effectivement à terme
les parents accueillent l'enfant des
weekends une partie des vacances
scolaires ce qui parlait au début on y
va très lentement il faut d'abord que
les gens s'habituent ils se connaissent
pas donc il faut qu'il s'habitue les uns
aux autres comment ça se passe cette
rencontre justement comment est-ce que
il y a quelque chose de type que vous
mettez en place ah oui alors maintenant
on a vraiment organisé de façon très
codifiée la première rencontre nous on
est tous ensemble les parents les
parents l'enfant ou les enfants et des
membres de l'association qui ont vu soit
l'enfance soit des parents et donc ils
font longuement très longuement
connaissance il y a aussi les
travailleurs sociaux si jamais des
enfants sont sous-mésure de justice ou
de travail social oui parce que
justement dans les Yvelines on a une
convention avec le département des
Yvelines ce qui fait qu'il y a
énormément d'enfants qui nous ont
présentés par les travailleurs sociaux
au départ voilà et donc aussi on les
voit au moins deux fois on voit une fois
les travailleurs sociaux et puis après
une autre fois l'enfant éventuellement
ses parents voilà ses parents pardon et
puis après du coup
on cherche la proximité et de goût et
aussi la proximité physique bien entendu
c'est important de dire aussi c'est que
c'est les enfants qui finalement
prennent la décision finale si eux ça le
courant de passe pas avec leur famille
ils ont le pouvoir de dire que
absolument je trouve quelqu'un d'autre
et puis au final c'est pas très grave
c'est exactement la mesure où c'est nous
qui forment les les appareils c'est nous
qui sommes responsables de la parrainage
enfant ni pour rien si ça mange si ça
fonctionne pas c'est pas grave on mettra
un autre parrainage en place et ça s'est
déjà fait plusieurs fois et
effectivement on finit par trouver le
bon parrain et la bonne marraine avec
qui ça marche bien l'idée c'est que
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui va
s'installer pour la vie et donc c'est
vrai il faut que ça soit vraiment des
relations des liens affectifs qui se
crée
en plus et en plus des parents bien sûr
il est pas question de remplacer la
maman d'Alice il est vraiment question
d'être en plus
vous avez trouvé une formule formidable
et les pas non plus question lorsqu'elle
est travailleur sociaux de remplacer les
travailleurs sociaux
et c'est pour ça que ça va durer très
longtemps voir largement jusqu'à 18 ans
ah oui notre trésorier par exemple
il a il est maintenant plus ou moins le
grand-père le grand parrain le
grand-père des petits qui ont 15 ans 12
ans 10 ans voilà et ils sont toujours en
relation et à l'inverse c'est quelque
chose qui arrive pas souvent mais si
jamais l'enfant veut rompre le contrat
qui est passé entre la famille enfin les
deux familles finalement il peut le
faire bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr c'est
lui le patron d'une certaine façon c'est
lui qui commande et vous accompagner
psychologiquement les parents aussi pour
pour gérer finalement cette relation
qu'ils ont avec les enfants exactement
et si jamais nous nous suffisons pas en
fait on a une psychologue qui fait des
vacations pour l'association et qui nous
est très utile parce qu'elle peut aussi
nous aider quand on rencontre les futurs
parents à préciser un peu leur profil et
les parrainages mettre en place pour eux
et en quoi c'est important finalement
d'être psychologiquement accompagné dans
cette aventure qui est quand même
importante émotionnellement
c'est vrai qu'effectivement les gens ont
besoin quand même de dialoguer alors en
fait on a des groupes de parole donc il
faut quand même un modérateur ou
quelqu'un qui qui sache le faire donc ça
c'est la psychologue qui le fait
justement et dans les coups de parole
les gens échangent ils racontent leurs
expériences du coup ça les renforce de
même que quand on fait des réunions
conviviales les gens discutent et du
coup ils se sentent rassurés sur
certains points qui pouvaient
éventuellement les inquiéter donc là
c'est très important parce que c'est
quand même psychologiquement c'est quand
même une vraie expérience quoi parce que
on a aussi énormément de réunions
conviviales où les gens alors là sans
être encadré peuvent se rencontrer les
parents les parents les travailleurs
sociaux les enfants bien sûr et vraiment
ça crée une émulation et les futurs
parents ont beaucoup d'intérêt à venir
aussi à ces réunions parce que ça ça va
ça va les inspirer peut-être et puis des
fois ils se sont ils se sont mis des
barrières et se rendent compte qu'elles
aient barrières ne veulent ne
conviennent pas donc on a vu et on a vu
beaucoup de sourires beaucoup d'émotions
dans le reportage c'est une aventure
humaine ça ça l'esprit c'est une
aventure humaine de temps en temps ça ne
marche pas voilà mais le plus souvent ça
marche formidablement bien tout le monde
peut devenir parrain tout le monde
absolument tout le monde alors des
couples des célibataires au niveau de
l'âge on a tous les âges de 25 à 70 ans
voilà avec enfants sans enfants avec des
enfants grands avec des enfants du même
âge mais effectivement tout ça ça doit
être bien approfondie parce que mettons
si vous avez des enfants du même âge des
fois ça se passera merveilleusement bien
et des fois ça se passera moins bien
parce qu'il y aura des petites jalousies
donc tout ça il faut vraiment le le
l'approfondir le gérer est-ce que vous
êtes en recherche en ce moment de
nouveaux parents
on a quand même une convention avec le
78 depuis 200 c'est vrai que de ce point
de vue là l'azo a été très dynamique
nous a présenté à l'ensemble des
travailleurs sociaux mais maintenant du
coup il faut qu'on retrouve les parents
en face et c'est vrai qu'effectivement
et en plus alors les réunions
conviviales à l'enfance
et donc les réunions conviviales sont
ouvertes à tous c'est-à-dire si les gens
veulent venir à une réunion conviviale
justement pour pouvoir discuter avec des
parrains des qui sont enfin des
parrainages qui existent déjà on les
invite à venir sans problème
ou un dernier mot peut-être Claudine non
c'est pour vous dire que hier on avait
une réunion dite d'apparinage et on a
encore casé quatre enfants de 78 en tout
on a au moins 27 depuis 2 ans voilà
d'accord et bien écoutez merci beaucoup
Claudine et Jean-François d'être venu en
parler avec nous en plateau si vous
souhaitez du coup avoir plus
d'informations n'hésitez pas à vous
rendre sur le site internet de
l'association qui s'affiche juste en
dessous et c'est l'heure pour nous de
passer à notre partie loisir
[Musique]
avec vous Grégory canalet vous allez
nous parler d'une bière made in Yvelines
brassée dans les Yvelines de la bière
locale chaque samedi après-midi elle a
brasserie de la petite sœur la petite
sœur même ouvrir ses portes pour
dévoiler ses procédés de fabrication une
petite question en plateau la petite
sœur pourquoi une bière pourrait
s'appeler la petite sœur Gabriel
je comptais vous poser la question
justement alors
Grégory souvent quand on va au bar dans
un pub quand on dit on remet la petite
sœur c'est que on veut reprendre un
verre derrière voilà ça ça vient de de
ce jargon de bar pour la petite sœur et
je vous disais ils organisent des
visites pour connaître toutes les
coulisses de la fabrication de la bière
sont gérants passionnés nous fait la
visite regardez je sais pas si certains
d'entre vous
connaissent un peu les méthodes de
fabrication des brasseurs espèrent
pas d'experts mais des passionnés
quelques curieux sont venus découvrir
les coulisses de la petite sœur
installée à Sartrouville en 2015 cette
brasserie propose des bières de
producteurs locaux mais aussi de la
fabrication maison au programme
présentation des ingrédients de la
couleur de la bière ou encore du
matériel de fabrication certains sont
surpris que parfois on peut mettre en
effet deux mois pour fabriquer une bière
ils sont surpris qu'il allait sortir de
tes fermentateurs la bière est sans
bulle qui est ne reformations naturelles
en bouteille la personne est très
dynamique elle présente l'ensemble de
des bières bon c'est un monde inconnu
mais j'ai trouvé ça un passionnant étape
importante le brassage des ingrédients
se fait en une journée dans ces grosses
cuves de 1000 litres les enzymes
transforment l'amidon présent dans les
céréales en sucre simple c'est là on va
mettre à peu près 200 250 kg de Malte en
sachant que plus on est de Malte plus on
aura une bière alcoolisée à la fin
on va mettre de l'eau chaude on va dire
entre 60 70 degrés et vous avez cette
pale qui va mélanger le tout alors le
projet qui est fabriqué de la bière mais
aussi le partager partager la
fabrication de bière partager le fait de
produire localement quelque chose bien
ou bliné note de réglisse d'agrumes ou
de banane point d'orgue de ce voyage
sensoriel une dégustation pour découvrir
les différents arômes de cette
production maison très très douce pas
d'amertume et un petit goût de pain
chaud de céréales ou de miel et ça ça
passe vachement il y en a deux sur les
trois que j'ai bien aimé la salle de
style irlandais puis la session a été
vas-y 60 000 bouteilles de bière
estampillé la petite sœur son produit de
surplace chaque année si vous aussi vous
souhaitez découvrir les secrets de
fabrication des visites gratuites sont
organisées les samedis à 15 heures dans
les coulisses de la brasserie
et donc Grégory vous avez suivi la
visite de cette brasserie qui met en
avant des bières locales yvelinoise mais
aussi participatif c'est-à-dire l'équipe
de la petite sœur souhaite vraiment être
un acteur engagé sur son territoire en
lien avec les partenaires locaux et les
habitants ça ne s'arrête pas aux visites
Mathilde l'idée même d'associer
directement les Yvelines et les
Franciliens à la création de recettes un
concept notamment c'est la soirée des
cobayes le principe un moment convivial
mais surtout de travail pour imaginer
une nouvelle bière entre les recettes
permanentes et les éphémères elle a
brasserie peut proposer jusqu'à 20
pierres différentes dans l'année qu'on
propose à des gens de venir alors sur
les gens me disent mais je suis pas je
suis pas un spécial je suis pas un
expert mais non vous avez un nez une
bouche ça suffit venez avec ça et on va
vous aider à créer cette bière et et ça
sera toujours plus
plus enrichissant parce que cet apport
de gens localement et en fait on
s'enrichit une mutuellement
et pour connaître les prochaines dates
de ces soirées des cobayes il suffit de
s'inscrire sur la newsletter de la
petite sœur
oui car elle mène des projets plusieurs
projets même de bière dites
collaboratives et d'abord avec les
autres brasseries de la région mais
aussi directement avec les habitants sur
un an ils vont penser la bière de A à Z
de la recette jusqu'au packaging
récemment la figolette a été créée avec
les habitants d'argentuil dans le
Val-d'Oise je vous laisse deviner
peut-être l'ingrédient la figolette
l'ingrédient principal dans cette bière
une bonne réponse d'ores et déjà alors
elle est déjà disponible en magasin
cette bière et désormais il y a un autre
projet qui est mené cette fois-ci dans
les Yvelines avec les croisillons
c'est-à-dire les habitants de
Croissy-sur-Seine je vous fais pas le
quiz pour cette fois-ci c'est une
étudiante apprenti brasseuse à la petite
sœur et qui est originaire en plus de
Sartrouville qui pilote cette nouvelle
recette j'invite les habitants de la
ville de Croatie à venir créer une bière
à l'image de la ville de Croatie donc
comment il a imaginé une bière qui
rappelle des souvenirs de leur ville
donc on est sur plusieurs projets donc
on les amène la brasserie on leur fait
découvrir le brassage comment fabriquer
une bière quel arôme on pourrait mettre
dans cette bière là il crie les tickets
il crie le nom ils sont totalement
pilotes entre guillemets du projet on
est là juste pour les accompagner
le projet a été lancé officiellement en
septembre dernier lors de la fête de la
carotte de Croatie sur scène quelques
réunions ont déjà eu lieu une douzaine
d'habitants participent pour le moment
allez l'élaboration de cette nouvelle
recette qui pourrait se baser sur quoi
alors Croatie Croatie fête de la carotte
donc la carotte donc peut-être ça va
partir sur la carotte mais ça peut être
totalement au hasard en fait au hasard
après une bière donc à la figue une
bière à la carotte
Gabriels à la carotte c'est étonnant
c'est étonnant en tout cas ça pourrait
être étonnant on rappellera bien sûr que
la bu d'alcool et dangereux pour la
santé alors le travail ne fait que
commencer pour découvrir le résultat un
peu de patience cette nouvelle bière
collaborative sera à dévoiler en
septembre 2023 lors de la fête de la
bière de Croissy-sur-Seine
notre page loisir avec nos idées de
sortie pour ce week-end c'est avec vous
Gabriel Gonthier qu'est-ce que vous nous
avez prévu et oui Mathilde comme chaque
semaine je vous ai sélectionné quelques
idées de sortie pour ce long week-end en
plus cette semaine on commence par la
découverte de roubadia alors orubaldip
c'est une artiste plasticienne
originaire de Damas en Syrie au travers
de l'exposition
isme portrait de femme l'artiste dépend
le déplacement des peuples contraints de
quitter leur pays ce qui est marquant
dans cette exposition sekoruba Dieppe et
à elle-même vécu l'exil dans chacun de
ces portraits qu'on peut découvrir c'est
une histoire différente qui est racontée
l'exposition est centrée sur la figure
féminine un moyen pour la plasticienne
de rappeler le rôle considérable que je
joue les femmes dans les pays déchirés
par la guerre et cette exposition elle a
elle est elle est à découvrir jusqu'au
20 novembre à la Commanderie des
Templiers d'Élancourt et vous nous avez
sélectionné une autre exposition elle
est située à Saint-Cloud et nous invite
à ouvrir notre regard et notre esprit au
déjà des frontières oui l'exposition sur
la route des nomades et consacrée au
nomadisme alors ce rendez-vous vous
invite au voyage c'est le fruit de 16
ans de découverte culturelles à travers
le monde vous découvrirez sous un nouvel
angle l'Afrique l'Inde ou encore la
Polynésie et bien d'autres et le but
c'est de faire découvrir de nouveaux
univers ainsi que des approches
thématiques plus vastes sur ces pays et
bien vous nous avez fait voyager mais on
revient au cœur des Yvelines avec le
marché fermier d'automne à la Bergerie
Nationale de Rambouillet et je sais
qu'il y a des fans de marché et de
produits locaux autour de cette âme le
visiblement dès demain et pour tout le
week-end la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet accueille 130 producteurs
des fermiers locaux et nationaux au
programme des dégustations de vins de
Champagne de produits fermiers et des
animations autour de la ferme je pense
qu'il y en a qui sont partants pour y
aller ce week-end ça donne un vie en
tout cas donc Claudine désolé il y a pas
longtemps avec l'association
et pour rester dans l'ambiance festive
un concert samedi soir a retenu votre
attention oui le joli concert soirée
s'installe samedi soir au Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines scène
nationale à l'affiche des artistes 100%
locaux de Saint-Quentin et de ses
environs le rap et le hip-hop sont les
genres phares de cette soirée et parmi
les artistes présents
prss et cette organisé par l'association
jolie prod exactement alors nous avons
déjà parlé d'eux sur cette antenne il y
a quelques temps dans le vyb avec
marmite FM l'association jolie prod
c'est une association à une association
locale et culturelle qui accompagne des
projets artistiques notamment dans les
domaines de l'audiovisuel le numérique
et les arts et enfin une exposition plus
solennelle mais essentiel dédié aux
écrivains persécutés oui cette année
encore des expositions sont dédiées aux
écrivains persécutés emprisonnés et
empêchés à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale du 15 novembre sur cette
cause la ville de ville représente
l'exposition quelques nouvelles de
derrière les barreaux qui met en avant
des textes d'auteur ayant connu les
persécutions à cause de ce qu'ils ont
écrit et bien merci beaucoup à Gabriel
Gontier moi je pense que je vais me
laisser tenter par le marché d'automne à
la Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet
est-ce que vous vous avez des
préférences je crois que je vais partir
sur le marché d'automne aussi je pense
que c'est unanime autour de la table
Nicolas dandry bonsoir
vous nous avez rejoint au plateau parce
que le jeudi c'est l'heure du quiz avec
vous et aujourd'hui vous nous avez
préparé un quiz sur la thématique du 11
novembre la commémoration de la fin de
la première guerre mondiale en 1918 ce
conflit qui a duré quatre ans et qui a
notamment opposé les Français aux
Allemands et justement du coup Nicolas
vous avez préparé un quiz alors pourquoi
je vous ai proposé un quiz sur cette
thématique là parce que et bien en fait
les traités qui ont mis fin à cette
guerre qui ont conclu cette guerre et
bien ils ont été signés dans les
Yvelines
et il faut savoir aussi que aujourd'hui
aux archives départementales des
Yvelines il y a une cinquantaine de
documents qui qui sont historiques en
fait qui date de l'époque et donc on va
commencer avec la première question j'ai
6 questions pour vous vous pouvez jouer
bien évidemment les invités vous qui
nous regardez sur les réseaux sociaux
vous pouvez aussi jouer alors première
question et bien tout simplement quand
est-ce qu'a été signé le traité de
Versailles 1919 alors oui mais alors je
veux la date exacte à la date exacte non
c'était 1919
c'est en juin vous avez une idée de la
date non bon allez on regarde la réponse
tout de suite
du 28 juin 1900 19
bien Gabriel viens vous progressez
Gabriel alors je tiens à préciser il y a
deux personnes qui ont une licence
d'histoire autour de cette table voilà
donc on verra à la fin c'est bon
pour la deuxième question et bien je
vous propose de regarder cette extrait
ce jour fera date dans l'histoire le 28
juin 1919 congrès de la paix au château
de Versailles après la défaite des
Allemands en 1918 les Alliés organisent
la paix c'est le traité de Versailles
[Musique]
congrès a-t-il été organisé à Versailles
selon vous
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez vous avez
une idée sur cette question en fait
alors c'est l'extrait d'un reportage
qu'on nous avions réalisé lors de
l'anniversaire de la signature du traité
alors pourquoi ce traité le traité de
Versailles a-t-il été signé au château
de Versailles alors je sais que je l'ai
appris
je sais plus Gabriel une idée les
invités un lien avec un événement
historique effectivement oui mais lequel
bien c'était c'est exactement ça en fait
après la défaite des Français en 1870 et
la victoire des Prussiens et bien le 18
janvier
1871 le chancelier Bismarck et le roi de
Prusse Guillaume décide de proclamer la
création de l'Empire allemand au sein du
Palais des Glaces de la galerie des
Glaces pardon du château de Versailles
et donc c'est vécu comme une honte comme
une honte par les Français et donc les
Français et les Alliés décident de
refaire de signer le traité de
Versailles en 1919 au château de
Versailles en réponse à cet événement
alors troisième question regardez bien
cette photo
[Musique]
qui sont ces deux personnages
historiques signataires du traité
[Musique]
alors oui allez
mon morceau effectivement et alors le
deuxième personnage historique
non vous avez pas d'idées
donc Georges Clémenceau qui est
président du conseil à l'époque la
Troisième République donc président en
quelque sorte du gouvernement et à côté
de lui il s'agit de Woodrow Wilson le
président des États-Unis de l'époque et
donc qui ont signé qui ont participé à
ce congrès avec ça et qui ont signé et
bien le traité de Versailles quatrième
question et bien on écoute tout de suite
cet extrait
du côté des Versailles et le maire de
l'époque Henri Simon l'ancien appel à
ses concitoyens néanmoins les édifices
publics seront pavoisés et illuminés les
habitants suivront certainement cet
exemple on parle quand même de
victorieux
comment a-t-on qualifié le traité de
Versailles
alors non comment qualifier le traité de
Versailles du côté allemand puisque là
on parle de victoire c'est célébré comme
une victoire je crois que en loge
Grégory canalet souhaite donner la
réponse Grégory vous pouvez venir en
plateau alors je rappelle la question
comment si j'ai mis sans histoire
un diktat un dicta voilà exactement la
réponse va s'afficher à l'écran
autre document conservés par les
Archives départementales les remarques
des Allemands sur les conditions de la
paix ce qui est intéressant aussi le
plus c'est un hectare c'est imposé ce
caractère très imposé de traiter le fait
qu'ils aiment été totalement exclues
totalement considéré comme un objet
deux dernières questions
cette photo regardez à votre avis à quoi
a servi ce bureau
je suppose que c'est sur ce bureau
qu'ils ont signé à traiter bravo Mathieu
effectivement
ce bureau a servi à la signature du
traité dans les collections de
Versailles au moment de la signature il
avait été déposé en 1914 de Château de
Versailles il était au palais de
Compiègne au 19e siècle dans le salon de
thé de l'impératrice Eugénie il arrive à
Versailles au début du conflit et
finalement c'est lui qui est choisi
comme beau meuble bel exemple d'un beau
bureau pour cette cérémonie de la
signature
bravo Mathilde merci Nicolas
en fait était situé au milieu de la
galerie des glaces et toutes les
délégations du monde entier sont venus
signer le traité de Versailles sur ce
bureau dernière question donc je vous le
disais il y a plusieurs tirs traités qui
ont été signés dans les Yvelines et donc
dernière question où ont été signés les
traités avec l'Autriche et l'Hongrie
puisque ce sont deux pays qui étaient
ennemis de la France à ce moment-là
alors allez-y Mathilde je crois que
c'est à Saint-Germain-en-Laye non oui
vous avez une réponse sur deux le lieu
exact je sais que c'est dans la commune
de Saint-Germain-en-Laye est-ce que vous
avez une idée où est-ce qu'aurait pu
être signé le traité avec l'Autriche la
Hongrie c'est pas à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est un autre
endroit Rambouillet alors non il y a pas
Rambouillet même s'il y a des événements
historiques qui sont passés à
Rambouillet vous avez une idée madame
non et ben écoutez on va écouter tout de
suite la réponse avec ce nouvel extrait
c'est les Allemands sont reçus au
château de Versailles pour une première
présentation du traité le 7 mai 1919
pour les autres et chiens cette même
scène à lieu au château de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le 2 juin au même
moment en Hongrie la dictature
bolchevique empêche les délégués
hongrois de se rendre à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye leur traité de Pey
aura lieu un an plus tard au Grand
Trianon à Versailles le 4 juin 1920 bon
j'espère que vous en avez appris un peu
plus sur ces traités historique qui ont
mis fin à cette première guerre mondiale
qu'on va commémorer demain avec le 11
novembre la signature de l'armistice qui
n'a pas été signée dans les Yvelines
mais voilà c'est un événement historique
et on a encore des traces dans le
département
merci beaucoup Nicolas dandry et donc
vous l'avez compris ce vendredi 11
novembre nous quand même aurons le 104e
anniversaire de l'Armistice de 1918 il
signe la fin de la première guerre
mondiale n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner
sur le site internet de celle-ci car
chaque commune des Yvelines organise une
cérémonie voici le programme dans
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines à Coignières le rendez-vous est
donné à 10h15 devant utilise
Saint-Germain d'Auxerre du côté de la
verrière les commémorations débuteront à
10 heures au cimetière pour maniller les
hameaux ce sera au carré de la mémoire
du jardin public Nelson Mandela à partir
de 10h15 la cérémonie débutera à 10h30 à
Maurepas au cimetière de la commune
attrape cet au monument aux morts à
proximité de la gare SNCF le début à
10h30 enfin Voisins-le-Bretonneux
commencera les commémorations à 11h
rendez-vous sur le parvis de l'Hôtel de
Ville
cette émission met juste avant de se
quitter je vous propose de jeter un coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin dans les Yvelines le ciel
sera brumeux le soleil aura un peu de
mal à sortir au niveau des températures
il fera 8 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 7° à
Versailles et 6 degrés à Houdan et
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le soleil
sera bien présent sur tout le
département au niveau des températures
comptées 12 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et aux dents à renvoyer il
fera 11 degrés
et pour ce week-end quelle sera la météo
Gabriel et bien comme vendredi Mathilde
le beau temps sera de la partie pour ce
week-end samedi matin les températures
seront comprises entre 9 et 10 degrés
sur tout le département avec un temps
ensoleillé l'après-midi même scénario il
fera 15 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Rambouillet le thermomètre
atteindra les 16 degrés à Houdan
dimanche le soleil reste majoritaire
avec tout de même quelques nuages les
températures seront comprises entre 8 et
9 degrés l'après-midi les nuages se
dissiperont et le temps se réchauffera
légèrement avec 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans Versailles et à
Rambouillet et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir reçu jusqu'au
bout avec nous je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur TV 78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]